tu es un bateau soviétique 25 américains
et 19 français si surveille en
permanence sans compter les sous marins
les microbes au travail 120 mesures
prises au conseil des ministres pour
favoriser la recherche biologique ski
mention passable pour pellen et sert à
elles se sont classés 5e et 6e dans la
première manche du slalom géant de la
coupe placide remporté par hanni wenzel
bonsoir il faut bien le constater ce 20
février 1980 le monde s'installe et sans
doute pour une longue période dans un
climat de grande tension internationale
en espérant que la partie de bras de fer
entre soviétiques et américains ne
dégénérera pas plus que jamais c'est une
question d'équilibré pour ceux qui sont
bon gré mal gré pris dans ce jeu
dangereux et planétaire c'est une
question aussi de souplesse et de sang
froid
ce 20 février marque l'expiration vous
le savez sans doute de l'ultimatum de
carter à l'urss pour retirer le gros de
ses troupes de l'afghanistan
or comme rien n'a bougé de ce côté là
les etats unis ont confirmé leur
sanction
leurs athlètes n'iront pas aux jeux
olympiques voilà ce que disait président
carter hier soir dans sa conférence de
presse
voilà cela c'était hier soir et
aujourd'hui est bien la décision
américaine est confirmée et si les
américains ne vont pas aux jeux de
moscou que feront les autres pays
occidentaux
c'est encore trop tôt pour le dire il
peut se passer encore des choses au
comité olympique international chez les
athlètes eux-mêmes et dans l'opinion
publique internationale
ce qui est certain c'est que les troupes
soviétiques sont toujours en effet bien
présentes en afghanistan
elles sont même de plus en plus aux
prises avec la rébellion
françois-xavier d'eau l'armée soviétique
a donc répondu à monsieur carter j'y
suis j'y reste
elle reste et se renforce ses effectifs
atteindrait presque cent mille hommes
c'est que la résistance devient plus
active marché en grève à herat et
kandahar
distribution de tracts à kaboul
embuscade sur les routes démoralisation
de l'armée afghane où les désertions
seraient nombreuses les forces
soviétiques sont donc amenés à prendre
l'affairé en main et leurs avions
bombardent des villages c'est le cycle
infernal de la guérilla et des
représailles
tout cela on l'a déjà vu ailleurs un
avantage toutefois pour les soviétiques
ils ont une frontière commune avec
l'afghanistan
ce n'était pas le cas par exemple des
américains au vietnam
bien sûr il n'est pas question que les
guérilleros de l'islam inflige une
défaite aux soviétiques mais ils peuvent
leur mener la vie dure pendant longtemps
sera suffisant pour inciter l'urss a
cherché un jour une sortie honorable
de toute façon le chemin de la
résistance afghane sera long et l'on
sait par expérience que de tels chemins
passe par des murailles et par d oradour
c'est bien connu les américains
voudraient trouver du côté des européens
soutient disons plus ferme
une solidarité plus nette dans leurs
actions de boycottage des jeux
olympiques à moscou certes mais d'une
façon générale aussi dans la riposte de
l'occident à l'urss car ce qui est en
cause c'est beaucoup plus que les jeux
de moscou
c'est pour faire le bilan de cette
solidarité que le secrétaire d'état
américain cyrus vance a commencé une
tournée en europe
il était ce matin à bonn
fédérale et cet après midi en italie et
demain elle sera à paris il aura de
longs entretiens avec notre ministre
affaires étrangères jean françois fond
c'est ça commencera à 9h30 du matin et
ça se terminera après le déjeuner on
peut prévoir que la discussion sera
aussi rude qu'amicale le ministre
français expliquera à nouveau que si
nous restons fidèles à nos alliances
nous voulons nous tenir l'écart des
blocs et garder les yeux ouverts sur la
suite des événements dans le monde
entier mais manifestement aux états unis
on comprend mal la position française de
washington
dominique bromberger autant la
déclaration franco allemande avait été
bien accueilli par la presse et
l'administration américaine qui en avait
d'ailleurs surtout retenu la
condamnation de l'intervention
soviétique en afghanistan et -
l'attachement la politique de détente
autant le refus de paris de prendre part
au projet de réunion à 5 de bones at il
provoqué le mécontentement des états
unis si dans les déclarations
officielles du département d'état ou de
la maison blanche
on s'est efforcé de minimiser le
différend entre paris et washington
les jours qui ont suivi l'annoncé
française ont vu en revanche se
multiplier les confidences orchestré de
hauts fonctionnaires qui soulignait ce
qu'il considérait être je cite l'aspect
zigzaguant de la politique française
vis-à-vis de l'union soviétique et qui
affirmait qu'il était stupéfait du refus
de paris
déclaration du reste largement reflété
dans la presse prenant conscience
ensuite du fait que cette attitude
risque est de donner l'impression que le
fossé entre américains et français
étaient plus profonds qu'en réalité les
mêmes officiels quelques jours plus tard
assurait que les politiques de paris et
de washington
si elle était séparée suivait néanmoins
des lignes parallèles et cyrus vance le
secrétaire d'état abandonnait l'idée
caressée un moment par certains de ses
conseillers de sauter l'étape française
de sa tournée européenne
tout cela devait aboutir à la
déclaration mi-chèvre mi-chou de carter
selon laquelle les relations
franco-américaines passe par des
périodes d'agacement sans que cela fasse
disparaître pour autant les convergences
entre les deux pays ces réactions
d'agacement ne sont que le reflet
atténuer d'une véritable exaspération de
l'opinion publique américaine qui estime
que les états unis se retrouvent seuls
pratiquement abandonné par leurs alliés
européens et surtout par la france
chaque fois qu'une grave crise
internationale se produit finalement la
faire des jeux de moscou paraît bien
mince dans la lutte d'influencé
américano soviétique en gare par exemple
de l'enjeu du pétrole du golfe persique
la région la plus sensible du monde
actuellement
d'où l'intérêt du voyage qui effectuera
monsieur giscard d'estaing début mars
dans les émirats
le premier ministre raymond barre lui
n'ira pas comme prévu en fin de semaine
en arabie saoudite sa visite a été
ajourné en raison de la santé du roi
khaled qui vient d'être hospitalisé
après un malaise cardiaque semble-t-il
deux médecins américains sont asus à son
chevet mais aussi tous les princes
ministre du royaume
et puis dans l'océan indien et surtout
dans l'âme érotomane que sillonnent les
grands pétroliers croise de plus en plus
de bateaux soviétiques et américains
entre autres
il ya là une gigantesque partie de
cache-cache que nous décrit jean-pierre
qui tarde pour les sociétés comme pour
les américains la mer dom années devenu
depuis quelques semaines un abcès de
fixation pour leur marine militaire
jamais encore on n'avait vu autant de
bâtiments de guerre il n'y en aurait une
soixantaine au total qui croisent à
portée de canon les uns des autres dans
cette partie nord de l'océan indien
stratégie oblige la merde oman regarder
la carte est un observatoire idéal pour
contrôler la route du pétrole mais
également pourrait servir de plate forme
d'intervention
si jamais les pays riverains du golfe
persique les plus gros producteurs de
pétrole du monde et est menacée d'après
les experts américains du pentagone ce
sont les bateaux soviétique les plus
nombreux dans cette zone ils en ont
dénombré 31 de grands bâtiments de
surface comme ceux-ci croiseur ou
destroyer lance missiles
sans compter les sous marins mais ce qui
les inquiète le plus c'est la présence
toute récente de deux navires transport
de troupes avec le chiffre paraît
riddick
man faible 300 fusilliers marins
capables de constituer une petite force
de débarquement ces bâtiments
appartiennent habituellement à l'escadre
soviétique du pacifique
ils ont rejoint l'océan indien il ya
quelques jours côté américain maintenant
on compte 25 navires parmi lesquels deux
porte avions géant le nimitz et le
corail
c'est monstrueux acier d'électronique 90
mille tonnes véritable aérodrome
flottant roggan à plus de 60 kilomètres
heure en barque plus de 150 avions de
combat comme le f 14 que voici le plus
performant et le plus moderne des
chasseurs embarqués
ce qui donne bien sûr aux américains une
très nette supériorité aérienne
et puis sous peu vraisemblablement d'ici
trois semaines
la flotte américaine sera renforcée par
quatre gros navire d'assaut amphibie
ayant à leur bord 10 800 marines qui
termine actuellement aux philippines des
manoeuvres d'entraînement
ces soldats d'élite arriveront au large
doman avec armes et bagages des chars
des véhicules blindés des hélicoptères
et ils pourront débarquer dans les plus
brefs délais là où le souhaitera le
président carter et puis en marge de
cette gigantesque partie d'échecs qui
est aussi une partie de poker politico
diplomatique qui se jouent à coups de
bâton et de soldats les spécialistes
militaires des deux super grand en
profite pour remettre à jour leur fiche
technique en photographiant les
bâtiments de surface en enregistrant les
empreintes sonores des sous marins
bref la mer dom année le théâtre
aujourd'hui d'une gigantesque revue
navale à l'échelle de la planète
soviétiques et américains pourrait s'y
sentir un peu seul s'il n'y avait de
temps en temps quelques bâtiments
français 19 au total dans cette zone qui
eux aussi regarde écoute et observe le
ballet nautique des superpuissances
la mise en place de la commission
internationale d'enquêté des nations
unies en iran semble particulièrement
laborieuse comme dit l'autre ça accroche
quelque part les membres de cette
commission sont actuellement à genève on
pensait qu'ils allaient partir pour
téhéran dans la journée mais leur départ
a été retardé le feu vert du secrétaire
général de l'onu curval dame tardait à
venir dans le courant de l'après-midi
curval jam annoncé une conférence de
presse puis il l'annulait et finalement
il la tenait cette conférence de presse
monsieur valdes m a alors dit que cette
commission allait se rendre à téhéran
pour entendre les griefs iranien et pour
contribuer à une solution de la crise
des otages dans les meilleurs délais or
ce que le gouvernement iranien attend
c'est une commission d' enquête sur les
crimes du shah d'iran
ce n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
finalement la commission d' enquête ne
sera à téhéran ne sera pas à téhéran
avant trois jours les américains se
réjouissent semble-t-il de ce que vaut
ce qu'a dit monsieur valdan
ainsi cette commission d' enquête ne
sera pas un tribunal distille le parti
communiste français a décidé de créer un
comité de défense des libertés et des
droits de l'homme en france et dans le
monde c'était l'objet de la conférence
de presse de georges marchais cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale
georges marchais qui présidera ce comité
dont georges séguy et louis aragon
feront partie patrick de carolis
assistaient à cette conférence de presse
où georges marchais a dénoncé les
atrocités du capitalisme qui dit il aux
primes des millions et des millions de
travailleurs tandis que le socialisme
d'hui lui réduit la misère fin de
citation
pendant une heure et demi devant six
télévisions une centaine de journalistes
internationaux georges marchais s'est
efforcé d'apparaître comme le seul
champion de la démocratie de l'égalité
de tous les êtres de la paix de la
fraternité et du bonheur pour lui le
seul responsable de tous les maux
c'est le capitalisme traduisons dans sa
bouche l'impérialisme américain le parti
communiste français entend donc
intensifier son combat d'où la création
du comité de défense des libertés des
droits de l'homme en france et dans le
monde
d'où également la publication d'un
premier bilan de ce que georges marchais
appel 20 années d'atteintes aux droits
de l'homme dans le monde
d'après ce document il semblerait que
les seuls défenseurs la liberté soit les
pays socialistes mais c'est la réponse
de georges marchais sur les jeux
olympiques que je vous propose d'écouter
l'impérialisme a peur de la tenue des
jeux olympiques à moscou il craint que
500 à 600 mille personnes puissent se
rend en toute liberté en union
soviétique et prendre connaissance sur
place des réalités du socialiste
d'aujourd'hui
la deuxième raison me semble est et si
ce qui se passe à la place à lake placid
en témoigne c'est que l'on craint
maintenant la confrontation sur le
terrain sportif on a peur de calculer
les médailles déjà les dernières
olympiades était éloquente de ce point
de vue je suis convaincu que les
prochaines le seront encore davantage
georges marchais a été aussi très sévère
pour sakharov
s'il a regretté les mesures prises
contre lui par moscou ils lui reprochent
à sakharov d'avoir je cite soutenu le
dictateur pinochet est à noter ici que
maître jacques miquel
l'avocat des familles de détenus en
argentine et en uruguay
c'est élevé aujourd'hui contre la
collusion entre l'urss et l'argentine
collusion qui je cite permet une
véritable international totalitaire en
empêchant la dénonciation à l'onu des
atteintes aux droits de l'homme c'est ce
que dit avoir constaté l'avocat en
revenant de genève après une réunion de
la commission des droits de l'homme des
nations unies
voici trois mois trois grands
professeurs de biologie remettait au
président la république un rapport
intitulé sciences de la vie et société
ces sciences de la vie ou biologie en
sont encore à la recherche fondamentale
qui sera renforcée a décidé de conseil
des ministres ce matin
lequel va créer également quatre centres
de microbiologie fondamentale et
appliquée et puis on veut renforcer les
industriels
gic est là le domaine est immense cela
consiste à par exemple a fabriqué à
partir des microbes de l'alcool
carburant du méthane mais aussi des
protéines des antibiotiques et c'est
seulement pour passer de l'expérience en
laboratoire la fabrication industrielle
il ya un grand pas à franchir
cesc est allé voir michel chevalet à
toulouse dans un des centres de
recherche
aujourd'hui l'homme re découvre les
charmes d infiniment petit des bactéries
qui travaille vite et bien avec très peu
d'énergie et surtout se multiplient tous
les 15 à 20 minutes autrement dit ce
sont dix usines qui sera fabriqué sans
cesse faire travailler les microbes dans
un but bien précis c'est cela la
biotechnologie mais du tube à essai à la
culture aux souches air industries
il y as place pour des années de
recherches pour des organismes comme
line ça à toulouse
ici on met au point les techniques de
demain on met au point les procédés qui
permettront aux bactéries de travailler
efficacement de produire de l'alcool du
méthane des protéines par exemple
là on cherche à multiplier les
micro-organismes le plus rapidement
possible dans le but d'obtenir des
protéines
là c'est un nouveau type de réacteur que
l'on expérimente pour favoriser les
échanges d'oxygène c'est l'un des
secrets d'une grande production de
biomasse là encore dans cette série de
réacteurs on veut contrôler la
fermentation alcoolique pour obtenir de
l'alcool et potec du carburant
industriel autre recherche la
fermentation méthaniques pour obtenir du
métal vous avez sous les yeux ne vaches
artificiel cette série de réacteurs
représente la panse et ce récipient et
son intestin d'où se dégagent des bulles
de méthane
une vache en produits 408 par jour ici
on est très loin du compte
voilà donc où en est la biotechnologie
ce n'est plus du laboratoire ce n'est
pas encore la grande industrie mais
c'est tout de même un formidable espoir
il y avait deux autres dossiers
principaux ce matin au conseil des
ministres
l'un concernait la formation
professionnelle et l'autre les veuves
alors pour la formation professionnelle
c'est un projet de loi qui a été adoptée
pour un plan de cinq ans destiné à
renforcer et à améliorer cette formation
professionnelle afin je cite de mieux
répondre aux réalités de l'emploi au
cours des prochaines années
on estime à 100 milles les jeunes qui
sortent de l'enseignement secondaire
sans qualification et on dit que 300
mille autres jeunes sont actuellement
mal orienté en ce qui concerne les
veuves
là aussi un projet de loi sur 4 millions
de personnes resté seul après la
disparition de leurs conjoints 3 million
deux cent mille sont des femmes des
mesures existent déjà en leur faveur
mais le ministre déléguée à la famille
madame pelletier présenté un projet de
loi pour améliorer ces mesures c'est
l'assurance veuvage bernard chevalier il
s'agit en fait d'une prestation couvrant
le risque de veuvage avant 55 ans
puisque les veuves à ce moment là n'ont
pas droit à la retraite de réversion
généralement soumise à des conditions
d'âge ainsi les personnes n'ayant pas
d'activité professionnelle et des
ressources suffisantes
ayant eu des enfants qu'il soit ou non
encore effectivement à charge pourront
bénéficier de cette nouvelle rente
dégressive elle sera versée sur trois
ans à partir du décès du mari son
montant mensuel aussi ré autour de 15
cents francs la première année 1000
francs la deuxième et 750 francs la
troisième
cette nouvelle assurance serait gérée
par les régimes de la sécurité sociale
et donnerait lieu à la création d'une
cotisation d'environ 0 1%
elle complétera en tout cas la
couverture sociale du risque veuvage
inégale selon les catégories
professionnelles celle qui ont moins de
55 ans il y avait un manque dans notre
système de protection sociale et le
ministre de la santé la sécurité sociale
et moi même à la suite et conformément
aux indications du président de la
république qui avait dit aux veuves oman
octobre à bordeaux qu'on allait mettre
en place une assurance veuvage
rent importante puisque au total 37
mille francs four pendant trois ans et
rendent qui atteint l'objectif
véritablement nécessaire puisque ces
trois années seront celles qui
permettront à ces femmes de retrouver
une activité professionnelle de suivre
une formation bref de se trouver un
nouveau vote de vie bilan de la
compagnie nationale air france comme
chaque année bilan où l'on voit que
malgré la mauvaise conjoncture
économique
79 a été une très bonne année pour la
compagnie française finit donc oublier
les traditionnels déficit air france
maintenant la compagnie affiche les
bénéfices 210 millions de francs pour
l'année pour l'année dernière pour 11
millions de passagers transportés un
chiffre d'affaires bien meilleure aussi
que l'année dernière ces résultats ont
permis la création de plus de 900
emplois l'an dernier il confirme en tout
cas le redressement d'air france
entrepris depuis cinq ans daniel duigou
grâce à son redressement air france est
une société nationale qui est en train
de prouver que le service public n'est
pas incompatible avec la rentabilité
air france a pourtant plusieurs boules
est à ses pieds c'est une des compagnies
d'aviation de plus cher à gérer les
rémunérations du personnel navigant sont
élevées elles utilisent un avion
prestigieux concorde mais qui lui coûte
cher 40 millions de francs 79 ans façon
trafic et parfois paralysé par des
grèves cause est peu cette année par son
personnel seulement deux jours mais
surtout par les aiguilleurs du ciel 40
jours en 79 mais malgré ces handicaps
air france a poursuivi son redressement
grâce à trois secteurs clés son réseau
sa flotte et ses tarifs l'objectif étant
la compétitivité sa flotte elle se
modernise avec des avions plus
performants boeing 747 airbus et 727 son
réseau il se développe en privilégiant
les grands axes des échanges commerciaux
de la france avec l'étranger comme
aujourd'hui le moyen-orient ces trafics
et bien au moment où l'on parle de
démocratisation du transport aérien air
france adapt de plus en plus ses tarifs
aux possibilités de la clientèle en
élargissant les qualités du service de
nouveautés la classe affaires et surtout
les vols vacances qui avec des prix plus
bas
les uns services simplifiés
ont remporté cet été un très grand
succès entre 75 et 82 % d'une
fréquentation pour les états unis la
grèce et les antilles pour l'avenir le
programme d'air france est ambitieux 39
nouveaux avions 3500 nouveaux emplois
d'ici 83 enfin le triplement des sièges
vols vacances pour l'été 80 reste que
l'on peut se demander si ce programme
n'est pas trop ambitieux alors que des
incertitudes pèsent sur l'économie
dans le long terme
indiscutablement avec une croissance
modérée de l'économie le développement
des voyages d'affaires le développement
des voyages de convenance personnelle
conduit des perspectives de croissance
importante de l'aviation marchande de 6
à 9% par an c'est à dire grosso modo au
moins le doublement en dix ans dans le
court terme nous ne sommes pas à l'abri
d'un certain nombre de péripéties nous
avons connu avec le pétrole et puis nous
avons depuis 74e perf et le perpétuel
stop and go de l'économie alors le
problème c'est d'être armé pour faire
face à ces péripéties c'est à dire
d'être souple et d'être compétitif est
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que la
france est en bonne condition et souple
compétitive est mieux armé que bien de
ses concurrentes pour faire face aux
péripéties que l'on peut craindre les
années à venir
d'abord quelques mots si vous voulez
bien sûr des démos désormais habituel
sur la santé du maréchal qui te galmard
et chats se sent plutôt bien aujourd'hui
sa résistance étonne même ses médecins
des médecins qui précise tout de même
qu'en dépit de cette rémission
l'organisme du chef de l'état yougoslave
ce affaiblit inexorablement le roi
baudouin de belgique a quitté hier soir
la clinique de bruxelles où ils avaient
subi le 9 février dernier
l'ablation d'un disque de la colonne
vertébrale tout va bien pour le roi des
belges a mexico les ambassades de
belgique et du danemark sont toujours
occupés en cependant par des militants
d'extrême gauche aujourd'hui ils ont
libéré quelques otages mais détiennent
toujours une dizaine de prisonniers
parmi lesquels les deux ambassadeurs
italie la vie dernière à milan un
industriel de 70 ans monsieur mazzarini
a été enlevé par quatre hommes qui
l'attendaient dans le jardin de sa villa
c'est le cinquième enlèvement déjà
depuis le début de l'année en italie aux
etats-unis un nouveau sondage cbs new
york times confirme le regain de
popularité du président jimmy carter
dans ce sondage 58
pour cent des électeurs démocrates se
prononce en sa faveur contre 23%
seulement pour edward kennedy
de plus en plus distant et donc
l'inflation record au brésil en 1979 77%
responsable selon le ministre du plan
les dépenses excessives du gouvernement
l'expansion des mesures et du crédit et
l'augmentation anormale du prix du
pétrole en france c'est précisément pour
éviter une nouvelle aggravation de
l'inflation que le gouvernement
s'apprête à durcir sa politique
monétaire et budgétaire dès la fin de
cette semaine ou au début de la semaine
prochaine
deux séries de mesures seront annoncées
le renforcement de l'encadrement du
crédit et le renchérissement des taux
d'intérêt et puis on va porter tout à
l'heure une première réaction une
réaction de monsieur bernard pons qui
est le secrétaire général du rpr aux
déclarations faites hier par monsieur
bart le premier ministre devant
l'association des amis de la république
française pour monsieur pons le pouvoir
a toujours sous-estimé la crise
pétrolière déclenchée par les événements
d'iran et puis monsieur pons déclare
aussi que la gravité de la situation
actuelle doit interdire à tous la
polémique
aussi suis-je dit il d'autant plus
attristé des déclarations sur les
problèmes économiques et sociaux qui
manque à la fois d'objectivité et de
sérieux fin de citation deux nouvelles
centrales nucléaires ont été mises en
service aujourd'hui celle de gravelines
dans le nord et de tricastin dans la
drôme mise en service qui avait été
retardée après la découverte de fissures
dans les réacteurs de ces deux centrales
au mois de décembre
on dira ce que l'on voudra mais les
français sont tous un petit peu grippe
sou beaucoup ont ce qu'est chez eux des
pièces d'argent de 5 10 ou 50 francs des
pièces démonétisé depuis ce matin alors
à paris comme la province
on a assisté aujourd'hui à des ventes
massives de ces pièces les cours de ces
pièces est un 5 à 7 fois supérieur à
celui de leur valeur nominale
c'est par hasard que la brigade antigang
vient d'empêcher une vaste escroquerie à
la sécurité sociale elle a arrêté
aujourd'hui à paris trois hommes qui
s'apprêtaient à toucher des chèques de
remboursement de la sécurité sociale
dix mille de ces chèques ont été
découverts dans une petite imprimerie
clandestine
chaque avec lesquels les trois hommes
auraient pu escroqué environ 25 millions
de francs ce qui est tout de même énorme
un nouveau directeur à l'inspection
générale de la police nationale il
s'appelle monsieur andré dire x qui
succède à monsieur guy denis
il ya quelques jours à faire valoir ses
droits à la retraite un sondage
intéressant également dans la croix sur
les français et la culture
34% des français déclarent s'y
intéresser beaucoup 44% ac et 21% peu ou
pas du tout pour trois français sur
quatre la culture c'est d'abord un livre
pour un sur deux c'est visiter un musée
où une exposition à noter aussi que les
femmes font preuve de plus d'appétit que
les hommes pour les nourritures
intellectuelles et pour la culture en
général mais que la vie familiale ne
leur laisse guère le temps de le
satisfaire
et puis comme nous sommes mercredi je
n'oublierai pas les résultats du loto
d'été quelques carrés que vous voyez sur
l'écran le 1 le 5 le 12 le 37 le 45 et
le 49 et numéro complémentaire le 31 le
temps demain des pyrénées de l'accord
sur la moitié sud du massif central et
des alpes le temps sera très nuageux
avec des pluies parfois orageuses
des vents assez forts sur les autres
régions après la dissipation des brumes
du matin le temps sera ensoleillé
toutefois les nuages seront plus
nombreux de la bretagne et du cotentin
aux charentes où quelques pluies sont
possibles
je les matinales sur le nord et le
nord-est les françaises perrine pellen
et fabienne sert à celles qui portent
sur leurs frêles épaules et dans l'eure
souple cheville tous nos espoirs de
médaille aux jeux de lake placid n'ont
pu faire mieux que 5e et 6e dans la
première manche du slalom géant
la seconde manche est pour demain
fabienne et perry non plus d'une seconde
de retard sur hanni wenzel qui était
aujourd'hui vraiment la reine de cette
première manche pierre torrès
perrine ayant dans sa tête un projet
bien ancrée s'est lancé dans septième
position après canivet faisait lui
réalisé juste devant tel le meilleur
dans une minute 14 secondes et 33
centièmes piste dangereuse gare à la
chute deux des six premières
concurrentes sont tombés ici marie
thérèse nadig championne olympique en
1972 et parmi les favorites encore et
puis un peu plus bas ursula concept
perrine que revoilà est passé sans
encombre elle réalise au passage le
quatrième temps intermédiaire mais à 47
centièmes déjà dany wendel elle finira
6e de cette première manche à une
seconde et 12 centièmes de wenzel plus
que jamais favorite puisqu'elle devance
irène et pelé sa suivante immédiate de
42 centièmes précédé encore par
christina kinshofer et erika hess
perrine pellen sera devancé aussi par
fabienne serra que voilà de deux
centièmes de seconde la première
médaille accessible celle de bronze et à
24 et 26 centièmes pour les deux
françaises erin connaît la fable
fabienne connaît la chanson on ne vous
dira donc avec beaucoup de
circonspection que peut être demain
serra sera bon
espérons le voilà dernier journal vers
22h30 avec joseph poli bien sûr et puis
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité oui après le
journal vous aurez indirecte de lake
placid